hola ángel es un placer si realmente
como bien comentaban en la introducción
a la nota hubo dos encuentros bastantes
cercanos por cierto el primero de julio
y el 21 de octubre el primer ocurrió uno
de los satélites de la constelación
starling pasó a 10 kilómetros
aproximadamente de distancia de la
estación espacial china distancia que es
muy cercana teniendo en cuenta que hay
personas adentro los taikonautas pero el
del pasado 21 de octubre si lo tengo
aquí anotado pasó a escasos tres
kilómetros eso es extremadamente
cercano y no se puede correr semejante
riesgo porque ante una posible condición
de un satélite de este tipo estable en
con estación espacial si no hubiese sido
una catástrofe realmente esto está
chequeado está comprobado por distintas
fuentes por lo tanto creo que en este
caso las
las quejas por parte del gobierno chino
son más que fundadas bueno y entretanto
hablaron de los tratados espaciales como
está regulado el uso del espacio
entendiendo además que china es uno de
los mayores productores de basura
espacial del mundo
exactamente como como bien decís es una
de las potencias que está enviando cada
vez más material al espacio hay un
tratado tiene un nombre muy extenso pero
básicamente lo podríamos calificar como
el tratado de uso pacífico del espacio a
partir del cual desde mitad del siglo
pasado con el inicio de la carrera
espacial distintas naciones y potencias
se han
acogido a dicho tratado el problema que
radica acá es como muchas veces sabemos
una cuestión es la formalidad de formar
parte de ese tratado y otra cosa es
cumplirlo y déjame contar que todas las
potencias están de alguna manera no
cumpliendo con ese tratado ante
distintas acciones como por ejemplo la
destrucción
exprofeso de satélites para probar
distintas tecnologías más allá de el
envío constante de material a la órbita
baja terrestre es una situación que
realmente está complejizando mucho sobre
todo lo que son las misiones tripuladas
porque ponen en riesgo justamente la
vida de los astros